from under-seen comedies and totally
insane gore-fests to introspective
dramas that have gotten lost in the
shuffle 2021 has contained a heap of
cinematic surprises that all deserve to
get their time in the spotlight here are
the most underrated movies of 2021 so
far
have you ever sat down and asked
yourself what if there was a power
rangers movie that also contained
grotesque gore and horror but was also
super self-referential if so then that
very specific film you're looking for is
finally here pg's psycho gore man is the
late night alien comedy you never knew
you needed it's a ridiculously cheesy
and self-aware story of a bloodthirsty
alien warrior brought back to life who
must do the bidding of a little girl as
she possesses the gem that holds all his
power an eye-popping comedically
anarchic film pg psycho gore man is that
perfect midnight pulp film to catch with
your friends this bizarre canadian flick
is filled with gross out horror
ridiculously silly humor and enough
eye-catching creature effects to keep
you entertained plus there's a heap of
silly performances and some truly
stellar costume and puppet work let's
hope that maybe we'll get pg's psycho
gore man 2 the return of alastair the
brain bot
it was nice meeting you it would be
nicer if you were dead
all right bye
with its initial release coming right in
the middle of oscar season where
attention was being lavished on a heap
of other films it's only fair to shine a
light on the white tiger this netflix
film was able to snag a best adapted
screenplay nomination at the 93rd
academy awards however other than that
very notable oscar nod this movie has
been flying under the radar however as
it's been compared to beloved films like
joker and parasite it's a film that
definitely deserves some attention
adapted and directed by critically
acclaimed director rameen barrani the
white tiger follows the young ballroom
as he tries to navigate the brutal class
system in india however his lower class
beginnings shape the world around him as
he tries to climb the capitalist ladder
a ladder that can only lead to the worst
places with an exacting eye lush visuals
and brilliant social commentary the
white tiger is a film worth seeking out
amongst netflix's wide array of feature
film options
are we destined to be miserable is
marriage really supposed to get worse as
the years go on if you're still happy in
your marriage 14 years in is there
something wrong with you like actually
wrong with you those are the questions
brought up in the intriguingly strange
happily a comedy that seems to have
slipped under the radar in these weird
pandemic times but it still delivers on
its off-kilter premise with surprising
results joel mchale and carrie bichay
star as the central couple of the story
who receive a visit from a mysterious
stranger who explains that their
wonderfully happy marriage isn't all it
seems to be what follows from there
would be too fascinating to spoil but it
all leads up to a fancy getaway that
isn't all that it seems it's a strange
and ultimately daring comedy that asks
the sad questions of life that we've
always been too afraid to ask ourselves
there have been plenty of documentaries
over the years following the lives of
the rich and famous especially musicians
and recording artists we know and love
these films can range from incisive
introspective looks inside the world of
an artist or just another piece of
puff-filled pr to boost an artist's ego
billy eilish the world's a little blurry
thankfully sits primarily in the former
category providing audiences a dark and
detailed look inside the world of this
particular brilliant performer we see
the emotional mental and physical strain
it takes to become one of the world's
leading pop stars the world's a little
blurry follows the entire songwriting
process of eilish's hit debut album all
the way to her titanic grammy award
sweep eilish comes across as a
wonderfully personable figure with
little desire for the glam of celebrity
and a hyper focus on the passion of her
songwriting and creative output it's an
epic and humanizing film one that gives
us that most wondrous and personal look
at a world that can often seem so far
away
is shiva baby a comedy or a horror film
more likely it's some brilliant
fantastically jewish amalgam of the two
it's a combination that's only possible
through the mind of writer director emma
seligman in this frighteningly funny
debut feature rachel sennat stars as
danielle a college senior who's setting
straight from her appointment with her
sugar daddy to meet up with her family
at a shiva but when these two worlds
suddenly combine the levels of anxiety
and awkwardness build in a most
nightmarish fashion the film features
some absolutely fierce and passionate
scenes of reckoning with growing up in
contemporary jewish america all packed
into a tight 77 minute run time in other
words shiva baby is the perfect comedy
to remind you of the horrors and
anxieties of the world and it'll give
you a good excuse to laugh and cry about
them all day
when all is said and done we'll all look
back at 2021 as the year when one of the
most ridiculously joyful comedies ever
made snuck into the world barbin's star
go to vista del mar is kristen wiig and
annie mamalo's long-awaited follow-up to
their oscar-nominated hit bridesmaids it
takes that same kernel of the power of
female friendship and explodes it into a
madcap adventure following two
middle-aged women taking the grand
vacation they've always wanted
let's go to visit del mar
where bridesmaids reveled in its down to
earth improv style comedic trappings
barbin's star feels like a muppet movie
where all the muppets have been replaced
by humans it's a bright and shining
absurdist piece of insanity with talking
animals evil villains and jaime dornan
singing a tragic love song to a flock of
sequels it's a film that will absolutely
make you grin from ear to ear and if
nothing else you'll never look at
culottes the same way again
the most important thing to know is that
derek delgaudio wants you to leave your
assumptions about him at the door that's
all part of the illusion both literally
and spiritually embedded in in and of
itself it's a filmed version of
delgaudio's hit stage show that has
confounded and enlightened off-broadway
audiences under the direction of the
legendary frank oz now available to
stream on hulu delgaudio's solo
performance and illusionary spectacle is
honestly better the less you know going
in even so be ready for a wonderfully
introspective piece of theatrical
filmmaking that dares to ask us all if
we really know who we are at the end of
the day at the beginning of the film the
text on the screen asks us to put our
phones away and it's advice best heated
for this wonderfully underrated piece of
magical filmmaking at its finest
if you're someone who's all in on the
world of comedic horror then you
definitely need to know about josh rubin
he displayed a knack for delivering
expert spooky laughs in 2020's scare me
which he directed as well as stardom now
reuben stays behind the camera for this
year's nightmarishly funny werewolves
within it's a movie that's also
inexplicably one of the most
entertaining video game to film
adaptations in recent memory based on
the 2016 mafia style game of the same
name werewolves within takes place in
the small town of beaverfield it follows
one ranger who's been tasked with
finding the hairy monster that hides
within this less than assuming village
anchored by a lead performance from the
always wonderful sam richardson
werewolves within has more than enough
laughs frights and genuine craft behind
the camera it's definitely worthy of
being made a new staple of the halloween
season and we can't wait to see what
reuben cooks up next
edgar wright makes his freshman foray
into the world of documentary film with
the sparks brothers whether you're a
lifelong fan of the notorious music
group sparks comprised of real-life
brothers ron and russell male or just
hearing of them this is just the thing
for you it chronicles the duo's musical
journey over 50 years and features
interviews with titans of the
entertainment industry wright's
signature frenetic and free wheeling
style of filmmaking is used to glorious
effect here to make you fall in love
with this dynamic duo as fast as right
did this is a huge year for the music
duo as they're also the songwriters and
creative voices behind the new leos
carrax movie musical annette who knew
that 2021 would be the year that these
genius creative voices would emerge into
the mainstream to encompass the world of
entertainment maybe it's just the way
the sparks brothers wanted it all along
it's unclear how we got to this
incredible point where steven soderbergh
is able to churn out at least one film a
year but why argue with something so
wonderful ever since his own retirement
in 2017 with the exquisitely goofy logan
lucky soderbergh has been steadily
releasing new films he's been taking
each film as a new chance to experiment
with form craft and storytelling
resulting in if nothing else fascinating
new cinematic entries on a yearly basis
and this year's film no sudden move is
nothing short of one of soderberg's most
entertaining and exciting movies to date
set in 1950s detroit soderberg's latest
zippy heist follows three gangsters
brought onto a blackmail heist tasked
with holding hostage the family of an
accountant played by david harbour with
enough twists turns and overtly
passionate screeds about the dangers of
big business and capitalism no sudden
move proves that when it comes to the
heist film soderberg isn't getting rusty
any time soon
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]